hey guys do you know on what finger a
man should wear his ring and what is the
meaning behind it in other words what
does it mean if a man wears a ring on a
certain finger do you know well that's
what we're gonna talk about in this
video let's get to it now just very
quick if your first time here on my
channel I'm Daniel and welcome to D LM
model lifestyle if you haven't
subscribed yet then please do and also
click that notification about so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's talk about rings when it comes to
rings the worst thing that you can do is
to make assumptions about somebody when
you see them wearing a ring on weird and
strange fingers that you're not used to
you have to remember we are different
cultures and it influences the way that
we dress now some cultures only wear one
ring which is the wedding ring here to
the unaffected the pinkie right so it
shows people that you're not available
that you are married that you have a
wife but then some men for example in
the Eastern Orthodox Church they wear
their wedding rings on their right hand
now you need to know apart from that
they're not really any strict rules when
it comes to wearing rings but with that
said there are a few things that you
need to take into consideration when it
comes to wearing rings uncertain fingers
so let's start with the thumb ring and
its meaning now when it comes to the
thumb ring a lot of cultures where the
thumb ring to show their wealth or their
power meaning their influence
now these rings are not thin they're
usually broad and bulky and very manly
and that's also why they fit really well
on the thumb which is your thickest
finger next up is the pinky now I'm not
a fan of a pinky ring but usually guys
wear it for a statement this is the
statement finger at certain times in the
past men wore pinky rings to give a
message or to show that they are part of
an affiliation like the American
grifters and members of the Mafia
showing their affiliation and in the
18th century most men especially in
England used pinky rings and then later
on in the Victorian times both men and
women would wear pinky ring to show
people that they weren't interested in
marriage at all but right now in our
time it's more about fashion than
anything else a pinky rings can also be
broad and bulky it comes in a variety of
shapes and traditionally had a typical
signet ring shape meaning it was slimmer
at the bottom band and got wider at the
top with a beautiful precious stone so
next up the index finger it was used
hundreds of years ago as a signet or a
crest the index finger actually used to
be the finger that men had a ring on but
today is very different most men
including myself don't really want to
wear a ring on this finger because you
want to keep it clear and also it's not
really popular at all but if you do want
to wear a ring on this finger you can
choose your own symbolism
next up the middle finger now it's very
uncommon for men to wear a ring on this
finger just because it's so
uncomfortable because it's right between
the index finger and the ring finger so
most men don't do it but for those men
who do kind of feel uncomfortable with
wearing a pinkie ring they then choose a
ring on the the middle finger but then
the ring is just a little bit smaller so
what does it symbolize well wearing a
ring on the middle finger symbolizes
responsibility and balance I actually
quite like the meaning responsibility
and balance but I'm not a fan of wearing
a ring on this finger because a lot of
people already use this finger to offend
a lot of people and I don't like that so
what about the fourth finger on the left
hand well I've already mentioned this
before most cultures use this to show
that you are married that you're already
taking you're not available but what
about the right hand well
most cultures were engagement ring on
this hand certain countries like US and
Europe South Africa we also do that but
then there are also a few countries that
actually wear their wedding ring on
their right hand like Germany Russia
India and some others but for those
cultures who do wear an engagement ring
on their right hand it is usually more a
simple nice plain ring but nowadays
fashion a lot of young guys just use a
nice interesting artistic ring as well
that carries its own symbolism so just
remember don't judge other people for
the way they wear their rings because
today is just personal preference
however wearing a ring on the ring
finger on your left hand
sometimes the right will always give
people the impression that you are
married now if you want to check out
some good options for good rings then
I'll have my best options for you in the
video description that you can check out
and then if you want more tips on style
personal development and check out one
of these playlists and I'll see you
there circe guys